victory for him sam congratulations
we got to say yesterday's game was
titanic epic
all those moves
how did you come back from such a
difficult game it was such a struggle
and end up with a completely reverse
maximal result yeah uh i mean i did it
to myself i blundered in the opening
and i had pretty much no counter play
for the rest of the game so i just had
to suffer and defend and i mean even if
he's more tired than me there's just no
way to blend her with white
at some point i just messed up and
he broke through
i've seen you in the gym working out you
that that takes a lot of
energy out of you but it also gives
energy as well did you feel like you had
the energy really to fight today against
fabiano yeah for sure i came for a fight
i mean i come for fighting every game so
i was ready your thoughts about the fact
that you got this great position against
fabi uh right from the opening he played
some some strange ideas yes i mean i
played a very solid opening and he
played d6 playing for a win but it's a
very risky move i've done it myself and
you have with e6
and what's the point of playing playing
like this just to avoid the boring
positions
yeah kind of knight the problem is i
usually play d697 before castling and he
gave me bishop g5 as well i was really
happy to play bishop g5
and then he weakened his position with
h6 and g5 you must have felt like
this this is some good stuff but he's
trying to beat you yeah well i mean if
he doesn't do h65 i'd probably play f4
and he's it's an eternal pin pretty much
so what were your thoughts why do you
think he's just he's he's desperate to
beat you and that's his attitude i think
he was surprised in opening and probably
didn't make the best choice with this h6
g5
why do you say he was surprised in the
opening oh i've never played this before
okay that's that explains a lot so he
was out of his preparation
pretty quickly uh then you just
yeah i'm just preparing f4 here and that
h5 is a good move f4 obviously d5 he
miscalculated something
here
this moment u5 was just i thought rook
a5 is a nice move for black but the idea
of
trying to go to g5 after all the
exchanges on f4
but d5 you didn't like yeah i think d5
just loses a pawn
after f6 g5
we saw this happen too
i just couldn't see anything for black
yet takes takes and then you uh you
subscribe to the yasser ciron school of
always
taking pawns for sure and now the game
got a little wild although maybe i
shouldn't have played rook f6 just play
safe rook f2 b3
uh-huh and then this happened and then
he moved this game yeah he was he was
trying to complicate the game you
decided it was a good time to take one
pawn and here everybody was voting
bishop f1 bishop f1 thumping it
automatic and you decided to stay sharp
with e5
uh the reason was i wanted to keep queen
f6 in the air to trade queens
but maybe bishop f1 is better i'm not
sure
just
it actually probably is because c5 game
i did miss rookie 8 here initially
that's what i did oh man
but then you still continue with very
sharp moves bishop e4
we thought your intention
with e5 was because you wanted to give
your bishop the e4 square bishop d5 okay
no without your intention oh sorry
so we thought wow sam's a genius he's
playing five and rook on seven i mean we
all want to play bishop f1 he goes f5
then my bishop plans on d5 that's a nice
idea exactly but
i mean he came up with something we
hadn't even looked at yeah
if he doesn't do it though it just looks
completely when he rookie six i go queen
b7 exactly
so he's trying he's hoping he's hoping
that you mess up
and oh that's wrong you you came close
you're doing your best i thought i
should take on d4 but i really wanted
the queens off at this point exactly but
now something really bizarre took place
you played this move and then he had his
chance to get back in the game and
what should i play fe2 looks like the
best movie
i just saw rook
ef8
and
didn't want to look at this anymore
because
i don't know you i think you guessed it
i guess you have to take the bishop you
could take on e6
one
f1 rook f1 well any time you see rook f1
you kind of stop and say no no there's
no way i was going for that no no no no
no no no no
right i guess the king escapes
king f3 king e4 yeah probably go for a
rune
and then i thought you were cruising
until this
but the move he had and it's really
hidden was it
well i think he was also thinking about
rook effect right once he noticed that
rookie seven just winning on the spot
right he stopped he missed rook gfi
so in this position if he had played
this
you were ready for
check mating thresh yeah uh so rick jeff
it's a nice one i
i don't know if i'm winning anymore
so here
apparently c5 king g7 is the key move
yeah the problem with rook jf8 is you're
not really threatening rook takes f2
anymore exactly because it's kind of a
difficult move to make it requires you
to see a little bit deeper but now you
are threatening yeah and in a bullet
tempo it's really difficult to play like
this with black
wow
wow so we he had a chance after all and
of course time pressure was a factor
both of you had we were relying upon the
increment at the very end but i know
exactly what you're thinking sam a big
relief to get off the queens but once he
took an april was really happy because
where's his face i go bishop and get rid
of that bishop yeah yeah now now it's
now now it's all but the crying yeah no
it's official and nice sam we're looking
at fabiano caruana and we're thinking
where's fabi i mean he's had a terrible
game after terrible game he could have
been minus four by now
as a person
you know you ha you win the game you've
got to be happy but how do you feel
about the fact that it's clear he's not
playing like his normal self yeah i mean
even at the start of the tournament he
was he's been making like positional and
tactical errors and
you know going into a game you have to
try taking advantage of that no matter
who you're playing so that's the thing
you think it's it doesn't matter how bad
you're playing i just got to beat you
yeah exactly no feeling sorry for the
opponent no no
no i said that pretty definitively all
right well good comeback for you good
place in the tournament keep it up thank
you
wow
we just got to say our congratulations
sam and uh to recover from yesterday's
incredibly you
in my opinion you were putting up a
heroic defense for six hours just as you
described it so well yourself you got
into a bad position you're defending the
whole game you came close to drawing
then to come back today with this win
just remarkable good luck for the rest
of the tournament well done
wow
holy smokes that was amazing